welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am Jesse dollamore host of the dollar
more daily on YouTube and the podcast I
doubt it
Congress today let's talk about
congressional committees specifically
let's
look at Great Duty and the work that
could be being done
by passing legislation to make the lives
of Americans better and easier
that is not what's taking place
Republicans have wanted power for so
long
they were willing to lie Steed and chill
uh lie steal and cheat as it were
to get it
and now that they're there it's chaos 24
7. it is Circus atmosphere 24 7. it's
getting nothing done
24 7.
Jim Jordan I mean and if you need any
more evidence of what the statement I
just made Jim Jordan is the Judiciary
chairman in the House of Representatives
Jim Jordan
and Matt Gates who's also a member of
the Judiciary Committee
offered up an amendment today and you
can you can judge whether you think this
is going to make your life better more
rich
easier I'll let you be the judge
he offered up an amendment that they
start every hearing of the Judiciary
Committee in the House of
Representatives by putting their hand in
their heart and reciting the Pledge of
Allegiance
this was the important work of Congress
today at least many minutes were taken
up by this debate
and rather than just go along with it
Democrats rightfully
push back on this
and we're going to talk about that but
for you know let me go off on a tangent
here look I served in the United States
Marine Corps for many years
I I don't understand
the Pledge of Allegiance I don't
understand
uh this this this attempted
indoctrination of our children of making
them recite this thing I know that you
can opt out of it but to to swear
allegiance to a piece of cloth
it it's very weird to me it's very
strange to me and for congress people to
be wasting taxpayer dollars trying to
get an amendment that they start every
session with the Pledge of Allegiance is
just their election it's insanity
and luckily David cisolini was there a
congressman from Rhode Island
to push back on this and offer his own
amendment that if you've participated in
an Insurrection or you're an
Insurrection apologist you don't get to
say
the Pledge of Allegiance watch this
thank you Mr chairman I um you know Mr
Isa just made a reference to how
important it is for us to display our
commitment to the Constitution and to
commit to defend it aggressively
so I'd like to offer an amendment to the
amendment uh adding in the second
paragraph where the chair May designate
an individual to lead the pledge of
allegiance to add the following language
provided however the pledge shall not be
led by an individual who supported an
Insurrection against the government of
the United States in any way
because I think if we adopt this
amendment then we will be truthful in in
representing that stating this pledge is
an affirmation of your defense of
democracy and the Constitution it's hard
to take that claim seriously if in fact
an individual who in any way supported
an Insurrection against the government
United States is allowed to leave the
pledge so I would ask Mr gates to accept
this friendly Amendment and I look
forward to supporting with a gentleman
yield I first asked Mr Gatesville
support the amendment
to make sure that someone who led an
Insurrection against the United States
doesn't make a mockery of the Pledge of
Allegiance and stand before this
committee with their hand over their
heart claiming to support the
Constitution Mr Cellini my concern would
be if your definition of an Insurrection
is objecting to electors then there
would be many Democrats on the committee
that wouldn't be eligible to lead the
pledge since so many that's not my
definition I mean the last Republican
president gets sworn in absolutely
projectors was George Herbert Walker
blaming Mike Thomas Gates I will allow
the chairman to determine whether or not
someone has participated in surrection
United States I think this language is
important with the gentleman further
yield I'm asking Mr Gates will you now
accept the amendment well I'm I'm
concerned that that you may be
disqualifying too many of your own
members Mr Sicily I'm not concerned
about that at all then agree to the
amendment
that's someone the right to stand before
the house Judiciary Committee and lead
the Pledge of Allegiance at a bare
minimum let's guarantee that that person
has not participated or supported or in
any way helped and overthrow of the
government of the United States with the
gentleman yield a simple proposition
got it this is a giant waste of time
I've previously stated that I still
think that but making the point is good
making the point that David cisolini is
making here is is a noble cause because
we need to point out hypocrisy where we
see it and especially in Congress we do
and that's a full-time job when you have
Republicans in leadership
to support
those who who attempted to overthrow the
United States government by way of force
by trying to delay the certification
by by violating the Constitution by
delaying a constitutionally mandated
certification of electoral voters
it flies in the face of this respect for
the Constitution you see a lot of these
goofballs who carry around in their
pocket a little a little pamphlet that's
the Constitution and they wave it around
and they act like they're they're
they're Noble Patriots don't tread on me
they say
yet they full-throatedly
some with Fists in the air and
solidarity like Josh Hawley supported
the Insurrection against the United
States
they knew what was taking place and they
supported it
so it's it's hypocrisy run a mock
for Matt Gates of all people to ask that
they recite the Pledge of Allegiance in
honor of our country as some
masturbatory patriotism because that's
what this is
they've watched their dear leader
literally hug and kiss the flag and they
believe that's the path to enlightenment
it's all just gross
but what would you expect when you got
Matt Gates and Jim Jordan in the mix
one of our sponsors today is zipix
nicotine toothpicks zipx brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipix has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 toothpicks you can
only get zipx online go to
zipxtoothpicks.com and get 10 off with
the code Pacman the link is down below